San Francisco is forcing couple to
remove sidewalk obstruction or pay 1400
fine it's a little Free Library okay and
by the way this story is by Insider it's
not even a story by Fox or anybody else
it's an Insider story on the left the
city of San Francisco has been cracking
down on unpermitted projects that
interfere with public ways including a
little Free Library owned by Susan and
Joe Myers who were threatened with a
fourteen hundred two dollar fine if they
did not remove it from the sidewalk in
front of their house the Crackdown is
part of the effort to remove decade old
awnings on businesses in Chinatown
benches constructed by residents and
other unpermitted objects the library is
popular in the Myers neighborhood and
many residents staged a campaign to save
it resulting in the letters to the city
from locals including a young girl who
begged please do not destroy Joe and
Susan's Library City officials have
responded by saying they will do
everything they can to make sure it
stays in place the Myers could have
obtained a permit for fourteen hundred
two dollars to keep their library but
they decided instead to work to change
the system as a result City officials
are considering cheaper permits around
five dollars for similarly free
libraries and benches and this is in a
city San Francisco which if you've been
in San Francisco 20 years ago incredible
City yeah if you've been to San
Francisco recently it ain't the same San
Francisco and that's their flight I'm
sorry that and so bad thing about it the
city is is gone to part of my
French and this is what you're worried
about this is what's pissing the people
1400 bucks leave them alone that's how
small that thing is it's small it's a
little baby a little baby angel it's not
in the way of people walking that's
right next to
but that's the fight Pat not the
homeless guy doing crack and shooting up
and they're giving them drugs on
the right that is pissing people off
well now we know the uh now we know how
the math Works in San Francisco you want
to put a free library up to actually
help people in your neighborhood
fourteen hundred and two dollars taking
a dump on their front lawn is free right
so that's so let's go back and take a
look at this is an example you know of
you know a of a liberal City Hall that's
just lost its freaking mind and it it is
indefensible even the residents of San
Francisco have to look up and say wait
wait what I still have needles on the
streets and you're still giving out
bleach kits and uh clean needles and
you're giving these out because oh well
we don't want the addicts to get HIV
well no problem that way he won't have
HIV when he has a fentanyl overdose on
Tuesday great and you have all this
stuff going on homelessness is a problem
and not just the homelessness but the
theft that goes with the homelessness
and the disease and what's happening and
the filth that's there that goes with
the homelessness okay so you're not
doing anything about that and by the way
to keep the police department from being
overwhelmed you know petty theft at like
500 is uh non-punishable they don't even
give you a jaywalking ticket nothing and
I think they raised it to a thousand
somebody's not done the chat and called
me out if that's not right but I think
they raised that so they did that so
that they wouldn't be overwhelmed so
that basically what it tells thieves you
know coach bagged three thousand dollars
in a Louis Vuitton bag two thousand
dollars don't take that laptop 9.99
perfect you know make sure that whatever
you take is under the threshold so that
you know you're not going to be
prosecuted so the liberal City Hall does
this and then suffers the embarrassment
and this is embarrassment from both
sides of the aisle on a nationwide basis
that something good that somebody
actually tried to do in the shadow of a
city doing nothing gets penalized no
good deed goes unpunished in San
Francisco so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]